hi I'm Erik Bosse and mission impossible
fallout was one of the most exhilarating
movies I've seen this year even if the
film is basically an excuse for Tom
Cruise to play Evel Knievel hey guys I
feel like jumping off a building today
so if you wanna roll the cameras cool
all right yeah let's make a movie let's
rewatch this movie scene by scene for
all the interesting details you might
have missed subtle Easter eggs and
callbacks to earlier films in the series
but also the cinematic techniques and
influences that helped the filmmaker
pull off this insane feat spoiler
warning if you haven't seen the movie
yet and let's get started okay the
opening shot of this movie is a dream
sequence with Ethan Hunt Tom Cruise
exchanging wedding vows with Julia
Michelle Monaghan Ethan's wife from
Mission Impossible 3 we saw them
exchange vows in the hospital chapel in
that movie and now this seems like a
more legit wedding ceremony but then the
vowel shift from vows of marriage to the
vows Ethan took as an IMF operative and
the ministers revealed to be Solomon
Lane Sean Harris the head of the
syndicate from rogue nation now this is
the first time a villain from a previous
Mission Impossible movie has returned
also the first time a director has
returned Chris McCrory said that in
order to make fallout feel like a
different movie from rogue nation and
keep up that tradition of each film
having its own voice he changed his
entire production crew with the
exceptions of his editor and a stunt
coordinator this dream ends with a
nuclear explosion wiping them all out
and the haunting visual of Ethan's face
and skull blasting away in the Asch
intentional or not this image definitely
echoes the nuclear nightmare of Sarah
Connor in t2 Judgment Day which ends
with the same kind of terror and of
course this drinks backdrop is this
Mountain Lake location which we later
learn is Kashmir shot and real-life New
Zealand this opening moment for shadows
the movies climax in which Ethan's fear
of a nuclear standoff in Kashmir with
Julia and Lane is realized
Ethan wakes up to receive his mission
which is given to him by a mysterious
messenger and they have this exchange
fate was forced his warrior a storm is
coming in the warrior responds back I am
the storm now a version of this is a
meme that has spread around online in
recent years Tom Brady actually quoted
it on social media as the Patriots
headed into the playoffs but yeah the
saying definitely reflects Ethan hunts
role in this story as a one-man storm
that can basically save the world and
his secret messages can
in a book Homer's The Odyssey The
Odyssey is a Greek epic poem part 2 of a
story following the Iliad and it tells
the story of the war hero Odysseus as he
returns home to Ithaca after the Church
of more to his Platonic ideal wife
Penelope the story of this movie is an
odyssey of sorts for Ethan it's part two
to the story of rogue nation following
war hero Ethan through a series of odd
trials as he makes his way back to his
Platonic ideal wife Julia even then sets
out to Berlin on a mission to prevent
Lanes followers the Apostles from
getting their hands on three plutonium
cores returning our Simon Pegg as Benji
and Ving Rhames as Luthor whom Ethan
decides to save instead of retrieving
the plutonium and from there the movie
shockingly jump-cuts to what appears to
be the consequences of that decision
detonations of those nukes in Rome
Jerusalem and Mecca the three holy
cities of Catholicism Judaism and Islam
but like the nuclear fake-out an Ethan's
dream this is all just a setup to get
Nils delbrück to talk and this trick is
also a call back way back to the opening
scene of the first Mission Impossible
film when the IMF team used a similar
phony set to get a guy to talk even
Luthor do a really good job playing up
this drama and notice what Luther says
it's not a wheel this is also kind of a
callback to and Ethan similarly try to
force a confession out of arms dealer
Owen Davian in mi3
which arguably could have just been more
theatrics by Ethan that just didn't work
in that case fallout ups the ante of the
Mission Impossible mask running gag with
Benji posing as CNN news hosts Wolf
Blitzer and then they're off to the next
step at the airport
Ethan meets with Alan Hundley played by
Alec Baldwin he joined the series in
Ghost Protocol as a CIA director who
then took over the IMF and rogue nation
but now he answers to CIA director Erica
Sloane played by Angela Bassett and her
special Activities point man is August
Walker played by Henry Cavill he of
course has a mustache which McCrory said
was intended to be a red flag that his
character is a bad guy this mustache
caused the most facial layer drama since
I showed up to my sister's southern
wedding with this I think got risers
from California in the middle of
production for this movie Warner
Brothers needed cavil to actually come
back to do reshoots as Superman for
Justice League asking him to be
clean-shaven but McQuarrie said that it
would have required three million
dollars in production delays for
fallouts who which the studio said
absolutely not so Justice League was
required to awkwardly cover up
Superman's lip using CGI which many of
you found distracting ironically fallout
leader did have to delay production
anyway when Tom Cruise broke his ankle
McCrory said that he felt bad for DC
over the bad timing but really the
takeaway is that with any contract
dispute in Hollywood just wait for Tom
Cruise to shut the city down by hurting
himself this leads to the amazing halo
sequence the first of many impossible
stunts in this movie right as it begins
notice how ethan snaps at walker to
follow his instructions or quote the
last thing to go through your mind will
be your knee cap is that clear and then
walker responds crystal that's a little
reference to Tom Cruise's famous line
about following orders in the movie a
few good men we follow orders or people
die it's that simple
are we clear crystal this jump appears
to take place in one unbroken take which
the director wanted so that we could
experience this all from Ethan's
perspective that's why when the
lightning strikes and the sound cuts out
for a couple seconds now this is
obviously super tricky to pull off they
needed one camera operator to hand off
the camera to another who performed the
jump with Tom Cruise and they shot it at
dusk with limited light so crews had to
stop himself midair three feet from the
camera with a three inch margin of going
out of focus the actors and the crew
would do five to seven practice jumps
throughout the day also they could wait
for dusk when the lighting would be just
right and at that point they'd only have
three minutes to get one take the final
version that we see in the movie was
stitched together with three takes Ethan
and Walker make it down to this party in
Paris where they're supposed to
intercept John Mark instead they run
into Ilsa Faust to Rebecca Ferguson the
mi6 agent returning from her Ignatian
and Ethan Walker Duke it out with the
contact they assume is lark played by
super talented stunt fighter Liang yang
McQuarrie actually acknowledged that the
fight choreography with these three men
in the bathroom stalls was inspired by
the physical comedy of silent film star
Buster Keaton whose work influenced the
practical gags you see in a lot of these
kind of movies and actually the
beginning of this fight as the two
closed in on lark from the sides you can
still hear the club's bass beat in the
background the director said that he
wanted it to evoke a heart beat to
reflect the intensity that these three
have is they wait to make a move and
after Ilsa shoots lark in the face Ethan
must take his place hoping that lark and
the White Widow have just never met in
person he actually pulls the same trick
with Murrow and ghost Protocol the White
Widow is played by Vanessa Kirby and her
speech is actually a tribute to her
mother someone named max she says max
was something of a paradox
she had a fascination for paradoxes
Ethan recognises these words because the
White Widow is the daughter of max who
was the character in the first movie
played by Vanessa Redgrave actually this
paradox reference is a call back to her
exchange with Ethan you are something
well that depends on the world whether
you like a paradox so this leads a white
widow to make an offer to Ethan she will
give him the plutonium cores in exchange
for him extracting Solomon Lane but
Ethan manages to avoid having to commit
any truly heinous acts as John lark by
going rogue on the Rogues
Ramy Lane struck into the river sin and
escaping the cops and Ilsa and the
widow's men all through the streets of
Paris now you may have noticed that
McQuarrie used a lot of low angles
street-level shots while Cruz zips
around the streets he said that he was
inspired by a short film shot by French
director Claude Lelouch called setae and
rendezvous which sped through the
streets of Paris from a car's low angle
point of view film actually got Lelouch
arrested after he screened it Lane's
extraction brings the team to these
London tunnels where Hundley initially
appears to pull Ethan out of the
operation but it's actually just all a
ploy to trick Walker into outing himself
as the true John lark and when he talks
to Lane he's actually talking to Benji
in
disguise which calls back the classic
Mission Impossible move from the first
movie in which the traitor reveals the
truth to someone they think is a villain
but is actually a good guy and Walker
snaps at him why did you have to make
this so effing complicated and that
makes the first time the F bomb was
dropped to the Mission Impossible movie
a shootout leads to Hundley's death and
Walker's escape and Ethan pursues him on
foot over the London rooftops now this
is a stunt where Tom Cruise shattered
his ankle and they actually use the
specific take when it happened you can
see where Cruz smacks into the ledge in
a way that no one should hit anything
and then he pulls himself over that
ledge and limps out of frame he's
limping because it's broken the first
part of this shot where he runs up
toward the ledge was actually recorded
months after this after Cruz healed
Walker escapes my helicopter and the
team follows them to this mountain
village in Kashmir which Ethan's initial
mission run down mentioned as the
disease outbreak containment site as a
mountainous region of India bordering
China and Pakistan it's a particularly
delicate region that irrigates 1/3 of
the world's population McCrory says that
his approach with his Mission Impossible
movies has been to really focus on the
geography of all the action most movies
begin with a pitch in a script which
then leads to the development process
where things change and then a
production process where they actually
make the movie but with rogue nation and
the fallout McQuarrie and crews worked
backwards from that they start with
which stunts they want to try and where
to set them so when crews told McQuarrie
that he wanted to set a helicopter chase
in a mountain pass they're like okay but
then they struggled to find a country
that would allow a big movie star to do
that eventually New Zealand gave them
the green light so McQuarrie Reese
staged the country's mountainous terrain
as the Himalayas and this third act is
set up to mirror the climaxes of a
couple past films like in ghost Protocol
Ethan goes solo to disable a nuclear
trigger while Benji and Luther and rest
of the team coordinate with support work
and like admission possible 3 Julia must
play an active role in saving the day
Ethan chasing Walker in the helicopter
was one of the most thrilling sequences
I've ever seen Cruz of course did all
the stunts himself including pulling the
helicopter out of a nearly
uncontrollable death drop something the
stunt flyer said could not be done and
dropping from the rope onto a cargo bag
something that looks so real that
McQuarrie said one of the crew members
radioed in saying I think we lost Tom
the chase ends with Ethan and Walker
having crashed on this slope cliffs
now while conceiving of the sequence
McQuarrie described the way two marbles
fall into a sink and how they eventually
collide with each other at the drain the
location Scouts couldn't find any cliffs
that were sloped like that in New
Zealand but they did find pulpit rock
from Norway so they use that to create a
virtual terrain to set the scene upon
during this whole sequence McQuarrie
uses a lot of mounted camera shots on
the side of the helicopter to put us in
the cockpit with Ethan so when his and
Walker's choppers tumble down the slope
we roll with Ethan this echoes the
visual earlier with Lane in the flooding
truck as it flipped this way the worst
physical danger that the villain finds
himself in the hero must also go through
in this movie and the final action in
the film calls back to early mission of
possible sequences first Ethan is forced
to climb the cliff side with his bare
hands like the opening shots of Mission
Impossible 2 and he uses the hook
harness of the helicopter against Walker
yep similar to how he used the
helicopters stuck wire against Krieger
at the very end of the first movie that
covers all the stuff I noticed but a
question I'll leave you with do you need
Tom Cruise to do all his own
death-defying stunts to enjoy this movie
look a big part of this series in the
marketing centers around the fact that
Tom Cruise is putting himself in danger
and don't get me wrong that's part of
fun for me too but with crews breaking
his ankle I just worry we're getting off
a little too much on the physical
punishment but the Stute is exerting on
himself yeah screw that I want Tommy
screams to be real
comment down below with your thoughts
and tweet me ah da BOTS their problem
new rock stars on Twitter for updates
under videos like this video share it
around and subscribe to new rock stars
for breakdowns analysis of all the
movies you love including all the Marvel
movies and Star Wars and DC all of it
thank you for watching and no but let's
end this video by jumping out a window
here I go
[Music]